it's bargain hunting time in the isles
of corporate britain
with the economy staging its recovery
from the initial shock of the pandemic
financial investors have gone shopping
the latest to get picked off the shelf
is morrison's the uk's fourth biggest
supermarket chain
as sky news revealed at the weekend the
retailer has attracted a takeover bid
from clayton de billiere and rice an
american private equity firm
clearly no body would be bidding for
this company
unless they saw there was some value
they could get out of it
and it's always been a an issue with the
city that they've
they've never rated the supermarkets
very highly all their shares are
undervalued
shares in the company saw today after
confirmation of the rejected takeover
bid
morrisons was valued at 4.3 billion
pounds on friday
before the offer was made public cdnr's
initial bid was worth 5.5 billion pounds
and morrison's values soared to 5.7
billion pounds
amid hopes of a bidding war the
bradford-based company could now be the
second of britain's big four
supermarkets to change hands following
asda's recent sale
that's despite the impact of covert 19
on the sector's cost base
which has only been partially offset by
a spike in sales to lock down consumers
much of the recent action in the grocery
sector has seen investors piling into
fast delivery apps like guerrillas
and guitea which has seen its valuation
sort of more than 5 billion pounds
and the interest in morrisons will raise
questions about how its workforce might
fare under new owners
i just hope that the owners of morrisons
hold their nerve and don't
take a short-term financial
uh goal for themselves uh and leaving
what is
you know the people that have provided
that that regular income for them those
regular
profits uh being left out in the cold
morrisons owns most of its nearly 500
stores itself
making its property portfolio an
attractive asset to potential buyers
it's not often a bidding frenzy breaks
out at one of the uk's big food
retailers
but there's now speculation that other
private equity firms or even amazon with
which morrisons has a partnership
will emerge as rival suitors city
sources tell me that cdnr itself
will lodge a higher offer either on its
own or with a partner
ahead of a deadline on july the 17th
morrison's routes date back to a west
yorkshire market stall in 1899.
today's multi-billion pound bid suggests
its 54 years on the london stock market
could soon be reaching the checkout mark
kleinman sky news